Із наближенням виборів в Україні
з'являється дедалі більше соціологічних опитувань про електоральні вподобання українців
Часто такими рейтингами маніпулюють
зокрема ті, хто їх замовляє
DW зібрала найпоширеніші трюки соціологів
Чим ближче до президентських виборів в Україні
тим частіше соціологічні служби включають
у свої рейтинги відомих осіб
співаків, артистів, спортсменів
Так, приміром, вже кілька місяців у президентських опитуваннях
фігурують Святослав Вакарчук
та Володимир Зеленський
І навіть входять у п'ятірку лідерів
президентських перегонів
хоча вони взагалі
не заявляли про наміри балотуватися
Це спотворює результати соціологічних опитувань
Прізвище Вакарчука у рейтингу, приміром
"відтягує" відсоток у опозиції
а Володимира Гройсмана, який не балотуватиметься, у Петра Порошенка
Найчастіше опитування окремих груп людей подається як всеукраїнське
або як повний національний соціологічний зріз
Опитування проводять, приміром,
лише у великих містах
чи лише у сільській місцевості
або ж нерівномірно розподіляють по регіонах країни
залежно від потрібного результату
Але називають це думкою всієї України
Тож у виборця складається хибне уявлення
про партію та її вплив
Якщо соціологам треба занизити рейтинг представників влади на замовлення конкурентів
вони вдаються до хитрощів
в опитуванні ставлять спершу запитання про соціально-економічні проблеми
на кшталт "Чи підтримуєте ви підвищення цін на комунальні послуги?"
А вже потім - запитання про електоральну підтримку того чи іншого кандидата
Відповідно, респондент несвідомо занижує
свою оцінку представників влади
Штаби кандидатів у президенти
перед виборами в Україні
часто взагалі не звертаються
до соціологічних компаній
а просто вигадують свої соцопитування
і відповідно їхні результати
Назви фейкових служб
при цьому співзвучні з уже існуючими
аби в українців стоврювалося
враження їхньої компетентності
Їх створюють переважно суто під вибори
Послугами таких фейкових соціологічних компаній
найчастіше користуються
маловідомі кандидати та партії
щоб оприлюднювати вигідні для себе рейтинги
і набирати таким чином додаткові голоси на перегонах
Перевірити їх можна у базі псевдосоціологів "Продавці рейтингів"
до яких потрапили 80 таких компаній